اذا مشاهدينا نبدا الخامسه من هذه
التصريحات غير المسبوقه لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اعلنت مقتل ثلاثه 63 مجندا بهجوم
اوكرانيا على معسكر تجنيد مؤقت في منطقه
شرقي اوكرانيا الوزاره ذكرت ان الهجوم
الاوكراني تم تنفيذه بصواريخ هامرز شديده
الانفجار وان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت اثنين
منها
ومشاهدينا طبعا هذه الصور وصلتنا قبل قليل
لموقع هذا الهجوم نشاهد دمار كبير وطبعا
اعداد القتلى كما ذكرنا قبل قليل وهذا
بحسب التصريحات الروسيه لوزاره الدفاع
الروسيه نتحدث عن 36
مجنه قتلوا من خلال هذا الاستهداف تم طبعا
الاستهداف همم من خلال استخدام اسلحه
شديده الانفجار وهمم الجانب الروسي يتحدث
عن ان الدفاعات الجويه اسقطت اثنين من
الصواريخ التي تمت همم تم
ارسالها واطلاقها باتجاه هذا المعسكر